日本で初めて美容院にいた時に紙を切って
もらう前に外国人の紙を切ったことあり
ますかと聞くべき
だ信じてくれ新しい同僚に土曜日空いて
るって聞かれたら仮に空いているとしても
その正しい答えはなんか入ってたような気
がするなでもなんかありますでありはいで
はない同元って土曜日の朝空いてます
土曜日の朝ですかえっとそうですねはい
ちょうど良かったですチームで死の
マラソン大会に挑戦しようと思っていて
是非同元にも参加してもらいたいんですよ
まマラソン大会最寄りの駅まで何分より
最寄りのコ市まで何分の方が大事だいや
あの伝えてしまって申し訳ないんだけど
あなたは彼女の最初の外国人彼氏じゃない
例え夜で急にユロBとか流れ出したとして
も山道を走ってる時にドリフトをする衝動
は抑えた方がいい新しいアパートに
引っ越したら綺麗なところであっても1番
先にゴキブリのブラックキャップを買って
それを部屋中に置くことだやが出てきて
からじゃ遅いからな日本の冬は空気が乾燥
してるから貸し付きが必要だ超音波式
モデルを購入するなその中ですぐにできて
しまうカビルンルンはアンパンマンだって
取れないあなたは実は納豆が嫌いじゃない
マックになれすぎているだけだいくら設備
が良くても3液以上離れているジムは1
ヶ月以内に行かなくなるあ怒ってないと
言ってたあじゃあ彼女は怒ってるね夜に
なったら安くなるスーパーのお寿司弁当
その匂いは食べ終わるまでじゃなくて
そして捨てるまでじゃなくてそしてその
ゴミの入ったゴミ袋を外に出すまででも
なくてそのプラスチック容器がゴミ処理上
で償却されるまでアパートに残るまずは
住所の書き方を覚えることあここに住所と
お名前を日本好きな人にとって日本で働く
ことは非常に楽しい特にその最初の1年間
は最高だえただし給料を縁でもらうような
仕事はやり出したらもう2度と自分の国に
帰れないと思ってもらった方がいい
でしょう地方銀行にお金を預けるより近く
の神社に行ってそれを金箱に投げ込んでア
テラスに祈った方がリターンが大きい外人
カードを使うかもしれないっていう場面で
は綺麗な日本語を使ってはいけないあその
旅行のことは誰にも言わずに行ってこよう
ウォシュレット高いからなと言って買わ
ない人が多いけれどはっきり言う値段以上
の価値がある1度でも食中毒になったら
それが明確にわかる日本のご飯を褒め
まくって悪いことは何もないけれど
ディスってしまったらジョニー染まりより
早く国から追放される10年をかけて
いろんな方法を試しては見たけど全部ダメ
だった日本ではラストクリスマスから
逃げる方法が
ない
til